dates 1960 targets fidel castro prime
minister of cuba location havana cuba
objective kill on sites
origins of this order stray from john f
kennedy himself
fidel castro was supposed to be an easy
target he ruled an underdeveloped island
didn't have a military anywhere close to
the likes of the us and he was in public
a lot
a well-placed sniper a bomb hidden from
his security team or even a drop of
poison in his favorite wine that is all
it would take for an assassin to get the
job done it couldn't be simpler so in
1960 the orders were given a cuban was
paid ten thousand dollars to shoot him
on sites it was supposed to be a
straightforward job except the guy never
got the chance fidel castro had gotten
lucky
the next kill order was given soon after
see during this time the american mafia
was at its heights and they had expanded
their operations like crazy one sector
they expanded into were casinos in cuba
not only are casinos a cash cow but they
are the perfect vehicle to launder money
the only problem was after castro took
power he seized the mafia's casinos in
cuba and the mafia was furious
so not only did the mafia and the cia
have a common enemy but the mafia had
the manpower and expertise to pull off
an assassination while allowing the cia
to keep their hands clean so the cia
went to the american mafia for help and
no this is not a movie plot this
actually happened the cia actually
wanted the mafia to assassinate a world
leader so they went to sam giancana and
santo trafficante two of the fbi's 10
most wanted and offered them 150 000 to
get the job done the mob went with the
poisoning routes trying to pour cyanide
into a chocolate milkshake castro
ordered at a restaurant
unfortunately the waiter who had to do
it got the packet of poison stuck in the
refrigerator door ripped it and then
spilled it all over the floor he
panicked and abandoned the job castro
survived yet again
after the mafia the cia got desperate
and so did their assassination plots in
1961 they tried poisoning his cigars two
billions of a gram of botulinum toxin
would be enough to kill him as soon as
he put the cigar in his mouth they even
got as far as tasking someone to swap
out his cigars for the poisoned ones but
again casual security was too tight and
the plan failed and this is where things
got really weird the ideas being thrown
around were wild fidel castro loved
scuba diving and swimming so they
planned on filling his diving suits with
tuberculosis bacteria that would make
him sick and eventually kill him they
just couldn't figure out how to get
castro to wear the death suits so they
went back to the drawing board they
thought about filling the seashells near
where casual like swimming with
explosives and for obvious reasons that
plan was abandoned they designed a pen
fitted with a hypodermic needle and
poison vial the pen was handed over to a
friendly cuban official who was supposed
to inject casual the next time he saw
him instead the guy got so worried he
would accidentally stab himself that he
threw the pen away and stopped answering
the cia's calls
this debauchery continued for four
decades according to fidel castro's
secret service chief the cia and other
groups made 634 attempts on castro's
life
every single time he escaped
was it luck or was the cia just grossly
incompetent
based on how badly the us government
wanted him dead it's pretty safe to say
that he was one of the most hated but
luckiest men in the world
but why what had he done to jump to the
top of the cia's hit list
this is the story of the world's
luckiest dictator
[Music]
[Music]
when murdering fidel castro didn't work
the cia turned to sabotage one of their
most famous plans was to sneak dally
himself into castro shoes that way his
skin would soak up the chemical which
would make him lose his beard in their
opinion castro's beard was iconic so
iconic that losing it would cause him
endless embarrassment and bring an end
to his reign although not all of us have
hair or beards iconic enough to interest
the cia preventing hair loss and keeping
your hair healthy is still important see
hair loss actually happens to 2 out of
every 3 guys by the time they're 35
which according to my youtube analytics
is creeping up real quick for a good
chunk of you that's where keeps comes in
keeps has designed a one of a kind
system a subscription service that gives
you all the best treatments to combat
hair loss right to your doorstep at half
the price of what you would pay at a
pharmacy here's how easy keeping your
hair can be you choose one of their
affordable plans to best fit your hair
situation a licensed doctor will confirm
is everything you need and nothing you
don't all online and then you set it and
forget it your keeps treatment is
shipped directly to your door every
three months at half the cost of your
local pharmacy because they use generic
versions of fda approved medications for
hair loss and then you start using your
treatment you can easily track your
progress online as you keep your hair
you have constant access to your doctor
through online doctor messaging and
although everyone is different people
who use keeps typically start seeing
results in just four to six months so
it's important to act fast the sooner
you start using keeps the more hair you
can save hair loss stops with keeps if
you're ready to take action go to
keeps.com jake tram with the link below
to receive 50 off your first order
seriously guys pause the video now and
your hair will thank you that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com jake tran with the
link below thanks the keeps for
sponsoring this video
fidel castro was born in cuba to a rich
plantation owning father his mom was a
farm worker and fidel was born out of
wedlock in school fidel was everything
but an academic genius he loved sports
especially baseball and spent more time
focused on that than schoolwork in 1945
he started studying law at the
university of havana and that's where he
developed his revolutionary flair over
the years he spoke out a lot about
corrupt governments and their presidents
but he was young and not seen as much of
a threat so in 1950 he graduated and
opened a law office to help less
fortunate cubans get the legal
representation they needed needless to
say the practice was a financial
disaster at the time the cuban
government was extremely corrupt all the
way up to the presidents cubans were
struggling to get access to medical care
and education and fidel felt like it was
his duty to try to make things better so
two years later at just 26 years old he
ran for election to the cuban house of
representatives up until then he was
trying to make a change the legal way by
following the rules but then right
before the election a military officer
named fulgencio batista orchestrated a
coup that kicked the sitting president
out of power and gave him control of the
country fidel had tried changing cuba
the right way he tried following the
rules but his chest had been stolen by
force by some american loving dictator
and that just wasn't acceptable it was
time to fight fire with fire
[Music]
when batista took power fidel casho got
really mad here was someone that had no
regard for the law or the cuban people
taking over their country and taking
whatever he wanted for himself in 1954
two years after becoming the leader of
cuba batista even held a presidential
election as a way to taunt the people
who didn't support his world he won
because he had no political opponents
the entire election was a way to remind
his servants who was really in charge it
seemed like batista had complete control
of cuba but he had overlooked one thing
the power of the masses one year before
the election fidel castro and 120 men
had tried to take over the army barracks
in santiago cuba their planet failed and
they were all sent to jail his fixed
election had given batista a massive
confidence boost and he felt really safe
in his position so just two years after
being sent to jail he released castro as
a sign of good faith to the u.s and to
the cuban people he had been cooperating
with america since the start of his
reign but obviously the u.s didn't want
it to seem like they were working with a
ruthless dictator so they asked them to
release the prison nurse and to present
himself as a little less dictatory
batista thought that by letting the men
go he would earn their gratitude but
castro just couldn't drop his grudge as
soon as he was released he fled to
mexico where he met the world's most
famous revolutionary che guevara
together with his brother raul castro
fidel and gavara planned how to
overthrow batista's reign in 1956 the
three revolutionaries and 79 other
people sailed from mexico to cuba as
soon as they arrived they were ambushed
by the government forces only 19 people
survived including fidel his brother and
gevara they fled into the mountains and
from there they started building their
army like i mentioned earlier batista
had underestimated the power of the
masses and this would eventually mean
the end to his rule in 1958 hundreds of
gorilla fighters attacked they ripped
control of cuba out of batista's hands
and on january 8 1959 fidel castro
arrived back in havana but not as a
lawyer or wanted fugitive of the states
but as the leader of the state himself
and he was ready to lead the people
fidel castro became the prime minister
of cuba his years of fighting for
equality had brought him to the highest
point of cuban governments and he wasn't
going to waste any time leveling the
playing field castro immediately started
reforming the government to fit his
socialist ideas he took land from the
rich including his own mother and
redistributed it to the poor he seized
control of cuba's casinos and their
millions many of which were owned by the
american mafia and used that money to
fund social programs like opening
schools and clinics he improved cuba's
infrastructure built hundreds of miles
of road and brought electricity to the
countryside this was at the height of
america's war against communism when
wherever in the world communist ideas
took hold america made it with force and
this time it was in their own backyard a
whole 10 hour boat ride from florida
castro wasn't going directly after the
u.s and a lot of what he was doing for
cuba at the start was arguably good but
then inevitably the money ran out
spending millions on fixing the country
without encouraging free enterprise
meant that no new money was coming in
suddenly cash would turn on u.s owned
farmlands and businesses as a way to
keep the money flowing into the
government coffers that was already
enough to annoy the americans but it was
about to get a lot worse when money
started getting tights cash returned to
the soviet union for cash in exchange
for crude oil fertilizers industrial
goods and 100 million dollar loan casho
agreed to provide the soviets with sugar
fruit and animal hides all the things
the u.s have been importing from cuba
for decades this infuriated and
frightened the american government even
more their neighbor was getting a little
too close to the enemy that wanted to
destroy them what would happen if cuba
became a communist country it was so
close to america the soviets could set
up military bases missiles nuclear
weapons right at america's doorstep
something had to be done as part of his
deal with the soviets castro ordered oil
refineries to process soviet crude oil
cuba's oil refineries were controlled by
american companies like shell and esso
so obviously they refused in retaliation
castro nationalized the refineries which
is a rosy way of saying he stole them
from the american oil giant at gunpoint
and put them under the control of the
cuban governments if there's anything
history has taught us about getting in
the way of america's love for oil is
that it's a great way of getting to the
top of america's list of countries to
liberate the u.s started by canceling
their imports of sugar from cuba one of
the country's biggest exports cashflow
proceeded to remind america that two
could play that game and nationalize the
sugar mills needless to say things were
not going well between the two countries
and it didn't get any better when a ship
from belgium carrying weapons to cuba
exploded in the havana harbor castro
accused the americans who said they had
nothing to do with it but by then the
fight was on the u.s tried to invade
cuba and kick cash for out in 1961 the
infamous bay of pigs invasion which
failed horribly
in retaliation casho got even more
involved in helping the soviets openly
declared his government to be socialists
and even let the soviets store their
nukes on the island and that was the
final straw castro had to go and america
didn't care what they had to do to get
rid of him
[Music]
right at the start of cashflow's rule
the cia and us government had tried
quietly getting rid of him there were
exploding cigars poison wetsuits
hypodermic pen needles and at least five
other well-documented assassination
attempts over the years at one point the
cia even got one of castro's mistresses
marita lorenz to kill him but her nerves
failed and she confessed there was even
a special cia operation codenamed
executive action whose sole purpose was
to find ways to get rid of castro they
tried everything from sabotage to
straightforward murder but with every
attempt castro just seemed to be a
little luckier than they were even after
caa director richard helms said all
assassination attempts on foreign
leaders needs to stop in 1972 it seemed
like castro was the exception the
attempts to kill castro continue right
up to the year 2000 way after the cold
war ended when the cia planted 90 kilos
of explosives under a stage in panama
where castro would give a speech
unfortunately for them his security team
found the bomb when he arrived and the
die-hard dictator survived again it had
taken over 600 tries millions of dollars
and countless cia agents to try to kill
the leader of cuba but after hundreds of
failed assassinations fidel castro
finally died on november 25th 2016 from
natural causes
the man survived 40 years of the cia
trying to kill him to die of old age at
90 years old
[Music]
the cia's assassination attempts on
castro were insane but it looks like
child play compared to the most dark
disturbing period in cia history mk
ultra the cia's quest for mind control
to give you a sense of how deranged
these experiments were one of them
involved victims being moved into an
isolation ward where they would only be
given enough food water and oxygen to
survive then they would be fed massive
amounts of lsd and then they would have
helmets strapped onto them with
headphones blasting messages like my
mother hates me into their ear hundreds
of thousands of times unfortunately this
stuff is a little too dark for youtube's
liking and would definitely get them
monetized that's why i just published a
feature length documentary on mkultra
available only to members of this
channel it's really good i'm really
proud of it and if you want to watch it
right now all you have to do is click
the join button below or use the link in
the description if you don't see the
join button from there you'll get
instant access to this documentary and
our previous one on monsanto the company
that owns the world's food supply along
with every other upcoming private
documentary i release every single month
with the next one being a very juicy one
on everyone's favorite guy that owned a
private island efforty jeffstein the
best part is you get all this knowledge
on how the world really works that
they'll never teach you in business
school for just five dollars a month and
if you join and don't think it's worth
it email me and i will personally refund
you the money click that join button
below to watch now
[Music]
you